at the end of the day i believe in me i
know what i have in the tank
um and we're talking about ages 32 like
i'm young
like in football you can say it oh but
you either do it or you don't
you know um this game don't change for
me uh i'm still fast and still strong
um and to you know the games last year i
just you know had an issue
where i didn't take enough time to heal
up properly
but you know that was just my decision
on going out there and just playing um
there's no excuses things like that but
um i'll be ready to go so um
for those who um questioning my health
and things like that just stay tuned
julio jones entering year number 11 kind
of came close to admitting he could have
played those nine games last year i mean
that's what people around the league are
thinking that he wasn't happy in atlanta
the team wasn't very good why are you
going to risk significant injury to your
hamstring
you know if everything was great you
were happy with your contract happy with
your situation maybe you go play
but one of the reasons why i think he's
not there anymore so overrated
underrated or properly rated
where do you think julio jones is right
now just given the way he's perceived at
this point in his career
well do we still think that julio jones
is the best receiver in the league
because i i think he's you know top five
top
two to three to four maybe i wouldn't
put him past like five i mean because
for me right now the best is deandre
hopkins
then i gotta go with stefan diggs and he
led the league in receptions and yards
right i would put julio jones maybe like
right
under those two guys but it's not i
i think he's probably properly rated but
if people
think that because he didn't play as
many games last year that
he's not still one of the top
five guys in this league then i think
that they're wrong and i think that
they're underrating him but i mean
from my perspective i say he's properly
rated yeah i think he's properly rated
the question is how much longer can he
be
in that upper echelon of nfl receivers
not many
guys do it at a high level deep into
their 30s
jerry rice i think was like 37 or 38
when he had 800
1800 excuse me receiving yards in 95 but
uh for the most part
the clock ticks a lot faster for guys at
the receiver position especially with so
many young guys who are constantly
coming up through the ranks now
who are pretty damn good denver broncos
melvin gordon teams running back says
they don't get enough respect in your
mind miles are the broncos
overrated underrated or properly rated
i mean should we be giving respect
to a team that's having a quarterback
competition with drew locke
and teddy bridgewater like that's not
you know
a team that i feel like is really going
to be competing
you know for everything in the you know
excuse me in the afc
west at this point especially when you
got the chiefs there you got the
chargers
and you also got the like that so to me
they're probably properly rated if
they're not giving them very much
respect because i don't know
how good they're going to be and i was a
believer in drew locke there's
record of me writing about this at the
end of the 2019 season for the las vegas
review journal
but at this point man like uh
[Music]
i remember his buzz lightyear game
against the houston texans
i mean uh but and then sims and i both
thought he could develop into a
franchise guy it's been injuries it's
been
inconsistency and somehow somehow
the broncos have the ninth best odds
to win the super bowl what in the world
i
i don't unless unless people think
they're going to get aaron rodgers to
sean watson
yeah that's the only that's the uh
that's uh people are
betting the possibility they heard
something about the broncos trading for
a quarterback and it was just earlier
this week
that deshaun watson via kareem jackson
uh communicated the idea that he wants
to play for the broncos so if you get
one of those two guys then all of a
sudden you got a better chance you're
still in the same division as patrick
mahomes though
yeah yeah exactly oh and justin herbert
and it's not like the raiders are
terrible their
defense has just been bad but gus
bradley might be able to improve that so
the raiders are gonna be in there
probably second or third
right you know with the chargers and i
think we all expect that the chiefs are
still gonna be great because they have
patrick mahomes so
i yeah i just even if the broncos you
know were to get a qb
i don't think that solves every single
one of their problems but
obviously adding an elite quarterback of
a watson or a rogers caliber
is gonna make you a lot better instantly
all right uh and look i think that they
are properly rated because i would say
most people not people who are betting
on the possibility that they get aaron
rodgers deshaun watson and would win the
super bowl
i think that the broncos are properly
regarded they're getting exactly the
respect that they have earned
given the implosion that we've seen
since they won super bowl 50. they have
not been a good team they don't have an
owner and it shows from time to time and
their inability to find a quarterback
has been their biggest downfall
yesterday was the 14-year anniversary of
the finale
of the sopranos now are we doing the
full series are we doing the finale
matt overrated underrated property
rating is it the finale
okay let's do the full series miles i
don't think miles is watching us
much of it based upon what you've seen
and i think you've seen the first season
do you think it was overrated underrated
properly rated
uh i hate to say properly rated for all
three topics but like
what from what i've seen it's very very
good and i know i really need to watch
this series it's been on my list for a
long time
i was watching it before i moved to
cleveland and then you know i just it's
gone out of the window since i've been
here so once i move again probably i
will get back on my sopranos vibe but
like
tony soprano is an all-time character
right like that
gave us the anti-hero of the genre and
we really think of this series as one of
the best series of all time generally so
i think it's pretty properly rated there
are
elements of it episodes scenes that
don't hold up
very well surprisingly and it stands out
when you regard
the the series as highly as you do so
i'll say properly rated
i'm not going to say it's underrated uh
there are some things where you see it
and it's like okay i'll let that go but
it's like that really wasn't funny or
that really didn't work or that didn't
look right or it seemed a little
i don't want to say amateurish but it
wasn't in keeping with the standard that
you
have so i'll just go i'll go with you
properly rated i think we all went
we both went properly rated across the
board let's take a break we've got
a special friday draft these are the
kinds of things we do when we don't have
any
ideas uh so stick around and see what we
came up with for today's draft we'll do
that next
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports